fox news cameras capturing
huge groups of illegal immigrants
crossing the border and they're not only
coming from the northern triangle
ghana you're from ghana brazil you're
from brazil you're from haiti
fox nation host tommy lahren is here to
react tommy more than
one million border arrests already so
far this year and you heard
those people say they're from ghana
brazil haiti so it's not just people
coming from the northern triangle or
mexico anymore
this feels like something has changed
what is that that's changed
it's very simple what's changed it's
called the biden administration and when
you've welcomed
a million plus illegal immigrants into
this country it is becoming a choice and
it's becoming an obvious choice
by the biden administration but as
you're seeing the message has been sent
around the world we are a free-for-all
we have open borders come one come all
and it's really ironic when you think
about it that the white house and the
government at large feels that
you know facebook posts about coveted
tyranny are problematic
but welcoming in hundreds of thousands
of people into our country illegally
untested
that doesn't seem to be a problem for
this administration so we really have to
understand
where they prioritize the health and
safety of americans as well as those
folks coming in because
at this point it's beyond a crisis it's
absolutely a choice
meantime israeli leaders are bashing ben
and jerry's for surrendering to
terrorism and anti-semitism
that's an exact quote for refusing to
sell ice cream it's ice cream in fact in
the west bank in east jerusalem calling
it
occupied palestinian territory tommy
they say woke makes you broke isn't this
going to hurt sales with those who
practice judaism
here in the u.s you know you'd think so
but i got to tell you guys i have long
since abandoned hope that leftist
companies were going to stand up for
my moral values and my moral compass i
wish we could return to the days where
companies sold
products instead of virtue signals where
everything wasn't a political statement
where sports were
about playing ball not playing politics
but we've entered this point now where
wokism has taken over
i don't believe in cancel culture but it
is time to look at these companies and
say
what exactly are you standing for but i
got to tell you guys this as well
i am far less so worried about what ben
jerry's
chooses to do and the possible
anti-semitic you know
choices that they choose to make i'm far
more concerned with those members of
congress
who are making those statements on a
daily basis and are getting away with it
because their own party is not holding
them accountable
so ben and jerry's yeah bad move but i'm
far more concerned about our elected
leaders that are doing far worse
yeah you know at the top you mentioned
how the biden administration
is looking at people's social media
posts the pentagon is also
reportedly working with an extremism
analysis company and they're searching
a service member's social media pages to
see if there's anything that they deem
as extremist content on them but they're
skipping slogans like anti-police
slogans
apparently that is fine and a former
space commander
space force command a space force
commander on the pentagon here's what he
had to say
very little surprises me anymore as i
continue to consider
just how focused it seems that the
defense department is
on rooting out white extremism and white
supremacy in the services right now
i'm not sure exactly how it is that
you're able to tell from
search terms that much about the
individuals that are serving in uniform
yeah so a lot of people say schools
hollywood have gone woke and now it's
affecting the military as well
oh it absolutely has become a social
experiment in a lot of ways we know
critical race theories seeping in
almost every corner of american society
at this point but it does seem like
they're far more concerned with rooting
out anything that they deem to be white
supremacy but really when they talk
about white supremacy what they're
really
meaning is they want to figure out who
the trump supporters in the group are
this has been something that's been
occurring for the last several months
and i would remind folks as well if you
want to look at extremist ideology look
no further
than the organization that is blm who
has had support for fidel castro that
has had support for defunding the police
demonizing police
and has been terrorizing our cities for
over i guess three plus years now
look no further than blm if you want to
look at extremist ideology
and what's truly harming our country the
military literally only has one job and
it is to protect america
i don't see how these distractions help
that mission with that
check out tommy's show no interruption
ooh they don't have the picture of you
with the finger anymore now it's just a
straight-on shot here tommy
things are changing uh this is only on
fox nation as always we appreciate you
getting up
on a tuesday yeah you don't have the
visual there but i just described it
enough for the nation
tommy thanks thank you so much